so you want to marry my daughter yes
yeah I mean I do I mean Mira told me
that you gave up a job in finance so you
could start a podcast life is short and
you gotta follow your dream how are you
going to support my daughter by
following a dream do you have like some
dream Bitcoin or dream 401k or some
I am going to give it everything I have
that sounds like some white boy I'm
given everything I've got
what's the difference between it is some
white for sure I'm gonna give it
everything I have all for one man one
for all wow that's a good
that impression but that's a good uh
evaluation of how I said that I'm gonna
pull the car over and do an impression
of our ass whipping in a minute
I don't I I can't imagine it without
having to see the impression of that so
we don't have to what's the difference
between me and you you talk a good one
but you don't do what you're supposed to
do